[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 72 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis campoy and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good thanks franceska how
you doing today
very good happy to have you back to San
Francisco and very excited to talk today
about not sre but CRE yeah
customer reliability engineering yeah
and we have nonetheless than Luke Stone
come with the father of the Siri
sure I think that yeah so you know like
pretty much the best person we could get
through Siri
he's here for these episodes so pretty
excited about that yeah super happy to
have him hanging out with the booth with
us then after that we're gonna talk
about the SRA things in our question of
the week I'm talking about
why can I have a 100% uptime I want a
hundred percent uptime I want 101 not be
like why not why no one offers 100%
uptime and if they do they're lying so
yeah we'll talk about that at the end
but before as usual we have our cool
things of the week and we have three of
them today the first one is a pretty
cool opportunity for any startup out
there doing machine learning we have a
competition it's called a Google cloud
machine learning competition because you
know it's like nothing better very
original name but basically if you apply
to it you can get up to half a million
dollars in investment opportunities and
1 million dollars in GCP credits and
there's many other places prices but
basically it's the whole point is if
you're doing the machine learning now
you can just apply it's not a specific
vertical of machine learning it's just
machine learning so I guess it's a cool
opportunity for anyone out there doing
cool stuff with machine learning yeah
and it's worth noting right we're pretty
open so teams don't have to be using
Google cloud platform to be eligible it
is US based startups but yeah so if
you're just basically doing machine
learning in almost any sector I'll know
most any platform and essentially you
know using any tech then you know we
could be interested in seeing you doing
next we're going to be talking about
something that I'm pretty sure people
that do machine learning especially at
are going to be pricks at about we
rolled up paper and published a blog
post about the performance of TP use the
tensor flow processing units and it has
a lot of detail yeah it's super cool so
yeah the tensor flow processing units
are custom chips for doing tensor flow
processing specifically for that task
and it's pretty cool so we wrote a blog
post about the performance improvements
we can see from running workloads on
sensor processing units versus GPUs and
it gets CPUs and I'm going to read this
because I sound super cool the TPU
achieves better energy efficiency than
conventional chips achieving 30 to 80
times improvement in terror operations
of computation per water energy consumed
so basically it does more for less yeah
it is for amazing there's a graph that
is not the easiest graph to know but
basically it says how much more
performance you can get per watt in
different systems and basically we have
two GPUs the faster TPU achieved almost
200 times more performance per wet than
a CPU which is a lot yeah so definitely
worth it especially if you're running
tends to flow there's no better place to
process test flow then at 10 some flow
processing unit yeah actually here's a
good one
have you ever used a TP you know have
you well have you ever used you to
search yeah
actually yes have you ever used Google
photos that's a very good point there
you go then you've used a TPU it powers
all those things right very good point
and the last cool thing of the week is a
very cool thing of the week that comes
from one of our dear co-workers bill
print he's a developer forms engineer
for Google cloud and he wrote a chrome
plugin it's called deep breath yeah so
if you're a little angry and you find
yourself writing an email that could
potentially I don't know get you fired
then this is a plug-in for you that will
let you know maybe that your email is
getting a little negative and will give
you a little pop-up saying you might
want to think about maybe turning that
down a little yeah it is pretty funny
it uses the natural language API and
what it does it's able to figure out if
your email is very negative and at some
point when the score of negativity goes
to high or low in this case it will warn
you with a pop-up saying careful these
email is getting pretty negative which
is pretty funny you know maybe maybe
I'll install that yeah I think that the
cool thing is that the whole thing is
open sourced so go check it out if you
have never used the API you'll see how
to use it it's actually pretty simple
and very nice example on how you can
build cool stuff that is also useful
awesome well why don't we go have a chat
with our friend Luke from the Sierra
team so I'm good letter that I am super
excited to have the most amazing
Luke Stone here from the Sierra team how
are you doing today Luke I'm fantastic
thanks for the great intro excellent
before we start talking about CRE and
customer reliability engineering why
don't you tell us a little bit about
yourself what do you do at Google what's
your role who are you as a person sure
so my name is Luke Stone I'm director of
customer reliability engineering for the
Google cloud platform I've been at
Google as an engineer for 14 years Wow
is it off doing tech support for Adsense
and I'm really into doing technical
partnerships I think Google isn't is an
awesome technical company and we have a
lot to offer to people who want to be
awesome at technology - cool so we've
done a couple episodes where we've
mentioned the concept of CRE but what is
it for you CRE is applying the wisdom
and best practices of Google SRE
to our cloud customers so sre is site
reliability engineering and it's
basically it's basically Google's answer
to DevOps yeah we've got a bunch of
episodes with fullness and volume so my
son also but also all the people not all
nuisance we talked a little bit of us s
re but s Ari has been there for quite a
while right
yeah Siri is premium yeah
when did it start how did it start CRE
started about six months ago
because we realize that our current
strategies of you know providing tech
support and you know documentation to
our customers was just not sufficient to
help people actually build meaningful
stuff on our cloud platform so let me
take you back I joined the cloud about
two years ago
mm-hmm and at that time we were offering
tech support to our customers and this
is break fix right so something breaks
and then you open a ticket and you fix
it and this is this is a great service
and absolutely necessary and it catches
everything that kind of falls through
the cracks but why do things need to
break in the first place mm-hmm when you
say things break you mean like break we
Google cloud or break on the customer
side or both well there you go
that's the that's the main problem here
is that when you're building on the
cloud you get access to a ton of
technology right but now your
application is made up of half of our
technology and half of your technology
in terms of your your application code
and systems so we really need to work
together and think of your your
application as one technology system
that we can collaborate on right and not
not just a typical engineering team
vendor type relationship because the
api's are vast and were really tightly
integrated what we did two years ago was
to try to make our tech support response
times better and make the quality of the
responses better but we noticed that
even the act of making a tech support
ticket takes several minutes right and
if you're working on an application that
has a four nines reliability goal then
you can you're only allowed four Meg on
time a month so you're gone right so we
really need to figure out so that that
wasn't going to that wasn't going to cut
it and we needed to figure out a new
strategy so we looked around the world
and so what's what's better and there's
there's a bunch of there's a bunch of
stuff out there in terms of DevOps and
people trying to do operations in a more
modern style than
the typical you know developers hate the
operators and apertures hate developers
sale but the the one that was most
natural to us was Google site
reliability engineering Google s re
because all the teams at Google operate
according to these principles so I
thought what if we just apply these
principles to your customer application
would it work and so with that let's
give it a shot so what does that mean
exactly doesn't mean that whenever
someone wants to build a new system
they're like hey I want to run these
huge web server serving millions of
people on an ev1 micro what's going to
happen or how does it work how does it
look like yeah that's that's exactly the
kind of scenario we're trying to address
so what we do is we we do what the the
same thing that Google SRV does with
Google applications when they're going
to go production right we have this
thing that's called production readiness
review that we do internally to Google
and we've adapted it to make something
called application reliability review
for your cloud application so if we were
to see your cloud application running on
f1 Micro we would say ok there's a risk
here is the risk right and and people
say well what's the risk well you know
the risk is that your input traffic is
unbounded do you have any idea of how
much traffic you could get no I don't
have an idea ok let's let's do some
capacity planning and modeling and see
how much traffic you could possibly get
ok now I have an idea ok let's do some
load testing and see if that instance is
going to stand up to it oh it's not ok
let's let's try to develop some you know
some playbook some odds ever see my
graduate census yeah yeah exactly
ideally some automation to help your
application automatically scale the
thing we noticed is that Google
applications are designed to scale from
the ground up and we have a lot of
infrastructure and practices in history
in Google at building web scale
applications so the s eries at Google
have seen hundreds of these applications
but in most
companies people are working on one you
know I danced there first and it's
probably the only one they're going to
they're going to deal with for the next
couple years so we have a lot of
expertise so we can share a lot of value
I think we can give by just just telling
people about what they're maybe going to
run into a little bit further down the
road now I'm quite curious you're
obviously without naming names and I've
seen some blog posts on this particular
as well but like particular lessons that
you found working as reac re for
customers who are looking to come on
board with Google cloud platform what
are like some common pitfalls or stuff
like that that people kind of run into
on a regular basis the best answer I can
really give to that is there's this book
called the SRA book which we might have
mentioned it a few times
exactly it's basically you know
collection of all the stuff that s/he
has found over time to that the
threatens the reliability of your
application
you know SRA is really a set of
principles that lead towards an
iterative process of improving your
liability over time so it kind of works
for almost anything and the you know the
core principles just to say them again
are know what your SL lows are right and
SLO is a service level objective and so
it's basically what's your what's your
expected uptime or what's your desired
of time and then have a consequence for
missing that and we call that an error
budget so at Google a typical
consequences if we don't meet our SLO
then we stop pushing new features and we
use the development time instead to
improve the reliability of our of our
system if you start with that it starts
to align incentives right and there's a
lot more incentives you need to align
between the developers and the operators
and the system owners and until you can
kind of get to a state where every time
something bad happens the response is a
positive response that ensures that it
won't happen again so I carry about how
that exactly works when you are on SLN
CRE because do you actually tell the
customer oh no you cannot push any more
feature
how does that happen that's a great
question so like the very basic way that
it works in SR is you have a post mortem
hmm
alright so something goes wrong and then
you you do a post mortem which it's a
very structured approach to it you come
over the timeline timeline of events and
you establish some basic facts so
everybody is an agreement we use a
blameless post-mortem controller so you
know if you broke something it's great
that you raise your hand and tell people
what you did exactly so that we can
learn how to how to avoid it in the
future so we do blameless post mortems
and then we go through you know what
went wrong what went well and what we're
going to do to prevent it happening
again and it basically turns into the
list of action items right you can see
how this will work to eventually squeeze
reliability risks out of the system but
in the very beginning you don't want to
just start waiting for things to go
wrong and then fix them so we can
leapfrog ahead and do an application
reliability review we sit down and we
look at your application and we use our
expertise about what's broken in the
past to try to guess what's going to
break with your application in the
future and we go through you know five
or six components of your application
and try to identify what are the what
are the biggest risks in each one of
these things we'll color them red orange
green you know in terms of risk level we
think about it in terms of the the
impact of the of the problem like is it
going to take your site completely down
or is it going to make it slow or is it
just going to be an inconvenience and
then the frequency you know is it likely
to happen once a day or once a month or
once every couple of years right so we
can make a matrix and think about you
know what's the potential impact of each
risk and then we'll give you a report
and say this is what we think is the
risk profile of your application they
might have two dozen things in it right
and so for each one of these things
we'll say
here's maybe what we would suggest you
do mmm then really you're in charge of
your engineering team as a customer
right near
building this application so you can
take this information you can take it or
leave it
and we fully understand that right so if
you want to fix all of those things
that's super great and we will we will
help you do it
and we will advise you on the best way
to do it and we'll help you connect with
the right people at Google for you know
feature requests or product gaps right
and we'll also take action items on that
list as well our selves to build things
that will make it easier to support your
application like for example if your
application uses a database that is
subject to some hot spotting right
because it's charted database like like
a datastore or a memcache service um we
would consider building tools to
identify a hot spotting to keep to make
your application more reliable so we
both take action items off this list and
then the deal is if we can get all the
critical action items off the list then
we can kind of go into a next phase
where we can operate it together with
some shared context right so now we're
pretty sure that it's not going to crash
for no reason at all right we're pretty
sure we've squeezed out most of the most
of the predictable reasons let's let's
agree that if we're faced with an outage
situation that we'll jump on a bridge
together and start debugging it together
that's kind of what we call a shared
operational fate which is really the end
state of a CRE engagement right and
that's the state that we we would love
to get to because it's the state that
most resembles the way that Google sre
teams work together to keep an
application going so it sounds like okay
so for CRE it sounds like the difference
between CRA and sre is like you seem to
be doing more upfront work than you
would do an SRE is that correct hmm I
would say I would say it's about the
same I mean it's very interesting
because that the SRE team at Google does
not support all Google products right
yep one of the principles is scarcity
right so you make sure that you support
the the most important ones and then you
give people an incentive
to work on their own reliability so they
can get to a point where it's kind of
fair to engage with another operational
team right because you've done your
homework and you've done all the basic
things right so in Google sre usually
the way you get access to an SRE team is
you go through a readiness review and
then you you polish off all the all the
known problems right and often it takes
many months like a year or 18 months to
really build trust with the SRA team
that that your development team is
thinking about reliability enough to
invest the SME resources into it as well
you know in that regard I think we're a
little faster to market in CRE but we
try to use the same principles okay cool
so all right so there's actually quite a
lot of similarity between uh sorry and
CRE just really it's kind of just the
end user more than it yeah yeah my job
is really so my job within the CRE team
is I'm the customer lead for CRE and so
what I do is I go through all the
practices of sre and I try to figure out
which ones actually apply only to Google
and which ones are possible to
generalize to all the customer base so
to get ready to get SME support at
Google I'm imagining that before you get
the readiness review review yeah there's
some kind of documentation that the
teams can go through and basically pre
valuate themselves before they go the
actual review is there such a thing also
externally like if someone some our
customers they're like oh like am I good
enough like what what are the best
practices that they should be following
the thing to start with is s ellos okay
that's really the tip of the spear the
SLO is really your contract with the
rest of your organization about how
reliable you expect your application to
be right and it's it's easy to say but
it's kind of hard to think about so
imagine a case where your application
goes down for you know one minute but
your CEO
happens to be using it right at that
right they're going to page the ops team
and and scream real loud but in reality
if you have if you have a you know an
SLO that's below five nines that's
probably okay it's within the expected
bounce so you need to have a agreement
across your organization that you're not
going to you know drop everything and
focus on a problem if it's within bounds
and on the other hand you have the
problems without a bounds then you need
to be able to say okay we're going to
have a consequence and we're going to
change our behavior in a known way when
we go out of bounds so it's a lot easier
to pre negotiate this stuff because it
takes a while to negotiate you know has
a lot to do with the headcount and
product release feature velocity and you
know when things ship and go to market
so it's going to be a little different
in every company I think but at Google
we use this concept of error budget
which basically says if your reliability
is is below your target and it looks
like you're going to miss for the month
you stop releasing right so that helps
to reallocate your development effort
towards reliability bugs and stuff I
mean everybody has a reliability backlog
you know it's called p3 and you're so
bug you does that mean the CRE team will
share like SLO s or possibly SLA s with
the customer once they're engaged is not
how that works so it's kind of like a
group mentality I guess that's right and
so what we're trying to do is distill
down the interface between our two sub
systems like we're running the
infrastructure system basically there
are the computing cloud computing
platform and you're running our
application and so we want to figure out
what's a really good contract between
our two groups about when we alert each
other so we want to try to think about
your application as being somewhat of a
black box usually we own a bunch of
networking and infrastructure at the at
the front end right load-balancing
external networking and stuff right and
then we have your application code which
is in the middle and then we have a lot
of services
like storage or pub/sub or something in
the backend so we try to think about
well what would be the indicators that
we could both observe at the same time
at those boundaries that will tell us
that the application is not performing
well and if we can agree on a few of
those things let's say we'll look at
load balance or error rate and latency
we can make a graph of that metric and
we can put it in a place where both of
our teams can see it right so now we
have what we call a shared state about
what's going on and if someone has a
concern about there's something going
wrong right we can both look at that
graph and see the same thing say oh yeah
wait a minute errors are way way out of
bounds yeah let's act right or we can
say hey what errors are actually in
bounds you know let's like hold off for
a second we're not going to we're not
going to hit the red button page the
world right so it helps a lot to get
into a rhythm of knowing what to expect
from the other team's behavior over time
and it helps to build trust and helps to
build reliability so we talked a little
bit about what happens when you are
about to meet your SLO what about when
you are way above your SLO I do I do we
do something with that extra error
budget or does that never yeah that's a
good like what we see a lot is people
are being really conservative about
their about their applications at Google
one thing we've done it's very
impressive is is to focus on our feature
velocity and how fast we can ship things
and to be thoughtful about trading off
how fast we can ship versus how reliable
we're going to be so often I see people
erring on the side of being too cautious
you know when you know they want to have
only five minutes of down time of year
when turns out well the internet you
know has an hour half of downtime and if
you're of a mobile application you know
you might be unconnected from your from
the application for many hours or even
days a year
people over optimized for reliability
and missed the chance
to ship features and get good velocity
so what we're trying to provide is
really a way to manage your reliability
according to your business goals cool so
I was reading on the announcement blog
post that was talking about CRE and
everything like that and it said on
their additional cost of zero dollars
what well that's so that does that that
does two things that are very important
first of all it sets the expectation
that we're going to have to work
together so it doesn't actually make it
easier to run your application reliable
reliably if you give me a suitcase of
money it doesn't actually help right the
problems are often in the design of your
service and you know does it have any
any features to auto scale or to drop
traffic when it's overloaded or to
recharge when it has a hot chart I can't
really solve those with a with a
suitcase full of money so what I really
need from you is I need time with your
engineering team all right so the
additional cost is actually zero dollars
but it's fairly heavy in terms of
engineering investment I want to work
with the tech leads of your of your
services and be able to and be able to
manage a to-do list with them meet with
them regularly and be in constant
communication right because that's
really what it takes to operate things
reliably the second thing it does to
offer $0 additional cost is it gives us
the ability to hand back our the pagers
if the service is too unreliable and if
you are not doing anything if you're not
basically holding up your end of the
bargain
in in Google we have this concept as
well and it's not because it's intended
to be executed frequently all we need to
do is show that that this is a dynamic
that can play out yeah and it gives
people a strong incentive to actually
you know carry their into the bargain
because really what we're trying to do
here is create a partnership cool so
like if you show up with like here's the
list of 12 things and they're like no
I'm going to do that
like okay then we're not gonna do our
bit either right exactly so we kept on
saying the the word customer and we've
interviewed some of them that are some
of your CRE customers we talked recently
episode 68 with the The Home Depot the
Home Depot Home Depot also we
interviewed at some point advise from
Niantic the Pokemon go what other
customers you can tell us about one it's
very interesting is pivotal we've been
working with pivotal on or Cloud Foundry
product which is basically a way to
build applications that can run on a
cloud a private cloud or a public cloud
with a lot of services for the developer
so the developer doesn't have to really
think about where's their code going to
run or what services can access their
there their concept is here's my code
run it on the cloud I don't care how
yeah right so that works really great
because we have a cloud um they have a
lot of software that's kind of
in-between the developer in the cloud
and we're helping them to understand you
know how that software is going to scale
how it's going to be reliable how to
monitor it on our cloud they're working
down a list of bugs right now you know
our voice to make it more reliable I
think it's going to be and then in the
nice way that that impacts the
marketplace is that it really scales our
effort right we can't like talk to every
single customer one-on-one right but if
we work with pivotal to make their Cloud
Foundry software really reliable then
lots of customers can benefit from that
and and we don't have to explain the
same concepts over and over and over so
we're getting a little bit close to time
but that's okay
so plans for the future for CRE where do
you see this thing heading I'd like to
work with them with our biggest
customers first the people who can
really invest the most engineering
effort with us and because I think we'll
learn a lot that can be spread out to
more to more customers over time of
course sre values software and
automation as a primary technique for
getting things done we're going to use
our first engagements that are really
person-to-person to learn use cases and
your modes and then we're going to
develop tools that will avoid those in
the future my plan is to work with like
order of tens of customers in the first
year and then order of hundreds of next
year thousands the year after that so
will will will get to the point where we
have some impact and you're getting some
value from our team even if you're not
talking to us directly and we plan to
you know we'll have features show up in
Google cloud that reliability features
well all right well we are running out
of time unfortunately I'd love to talk
to you for hours and hours on end but is
there anything we haven't mentioned or
you want to plug or is you just think
it's super super cool that people should
hear about that we haven't had a chance
to talk about one thing is that that sre
is as a concept is getting a lot of
traction you know in the DevOps
community and we just had s our recon
here in San Francisco and it was awesome
there was no hundreds people here who
were really really into it and they were
all adding a lot of value and sharing a
lot of ideas right so we we want to be a
conduit of that kind of information out
to the world as well and we'll be at
Google cloud next in New York City and
Seattle coming up with dates available
on Google cloud next website right we'll
have links on the show notes and I guess
it's time to say goodbye thank you so
much for coming and spending this time
with us in letting us know so much about
Siri hopefully looking forward to having
you again sometime soon to tell us about
how they grow into hundreds and
thousands of customers yeah we'll see
you next year David thanks American
Frances thanks so much to look for such
an interesting interview I learned so
much about how we interact with
customers when you know we're building
like big stuff very very cool yeah super
happy to have Luke on the podcast it's
really interesting to hear about how we
were engaging with customers especially
in enterprise level I'm sort of support
we're able to give them which makes me
super happy to say yeah it's basically
they're not our customers they are like
our partners on building cool stuff yeah
yeah you know I like that different
approach I really like it cool so I
think it's time to go
to our question of the week and today
the question of the week comes from
again Rakesh Rakesh junkie we answered
one of his questions on episode 17 about
protocol buffers and as soon as I sent
him an email saying hey your answer your
question has been answered he was like
well I have a needle question hey so
we're gonna be answering that question
now and the question is many many places
they give you an SLA right like they
give you
oh we guarantee 99.99 percent of
availability mm-hmm but why not 100
could they do it in theory you would
have 100 percent availability if you
never changed any code in theory I
actually do not believe that yeah that's
also true even even if you don't change
any code like if your system is
available through the internet the
Internet is not available 100 percent
that's true
so I guess in theory you could but
there's lots of stuff that can go wrong
in the process right so the interesting
thing is that you could have a 100
percent SLA yep service level of
griemann which means that if you don't
offer if you serve is that not offer
100% availability it means that they
will somehow compensate for it mm-hmm
that is an SLA that's true which doesn't
mean they will have 100 percent
availability because that is literally
impossible yeah as you said stuff goes
down things break but I think also like
it's to a good point that you're gonna
want new features to come into your
application or whatever it is that you
have to be building and any change you
make it's risk like yeah and there's
nothing you can really do about that
yeah we talked about this with poll news
and our dear full Nielsen on episode 59
so if you're interested in knowing no
more at this that's definitely an
episode that you might be interested in
listening to but I think that the most
interesting thing is what you were
mentioning before about like what is
actually five nines or six nines or what
to start with five nines does that mean
nine nine and five more nines or a
ninety nine dot and three nines because
it is ambiguous five nines 99.999% okay
so the two nines in the 99% our count
they're all 9th good ok
you never know but no so and this goes
to a good point and Rakesh allude to
this news question when he was like what
does it mean like that spanner isn't a
hundred percent right spanner has five
nines availability so 99.999%
availability
what does that mean for a
mission-critical applications and so you
actually sit back and can actually sit
down and look at the numbers wikipedia
has a great table on this and will link
it in the show notes but for example so
like five five nines basically per year
gives you five minutes and 26 seconds or
5.2 six minutes of downtime that's
that's what it means or essentially
twenty five seconds per month which is
not a lot not a lot and so the question
then you have to get to yourself is like
what is at the SLA of your application
Rakesh uses the term mission-critical
what does that mean right does your
application have to be up a hundred
percent at a time some applications are
like that that's early fair enough but
you know can your application handle
five minutes of downtime or could you
put in say a casing layer or something
like that to mitigate any downtime from
your back-end systems or allow for some
functionality but not all and I think
those are the sort of questions that we
need to be talking about when we build
software right we can't just be sort of
hand-wavy and say it must be up all the
time because otherwise bad things happen
we have to sort of think back and say
like software fails comforted
perspective that software fails let's go
back and talk to john wilkes again
because we can I was say that was
exactly thinking about that the episode
that we did with him were basically
bored and yeah also kubernetes are built
with the whole idea of software fails
everything fails let's build something
that is high I can have reliable on top
of something that is not those the
questions that should be should be asked
it's pretty it's pretty interesting we
actually break it down there you look at
the nines availability like two nine to
ninety nine percent that's just three
point six five days per year that starts
to be a lot I mean it does but that's
sort of like is that I am NOT available
that that's that's a service that's
seven hours a month like you know yeah
in some cases that could actually be in
ok SLA depending on what it is you're
doing yeah absolutely
um so yeah and on the on the massive L
of a part if you get nine nines
you get 31 milliseconds per year of off
time so yeah basically
I wonder if anyone has enough probes
like so often to be guarantee oh yeah
like officially drop one of the probes
is like 31 milliseconds off that that is
hard I feel like you would drop TCP
packets like you yeah Annie give you
head to check it there's some some
packet on that IP stream would end up
disappearing you're like upward weird
saris oh yeah I guess that 9/9 is
basically 99 to 100 are basically there
they're basically same thing and they're
both pretty much unachievable if you
have a service that offers 99 please let
us know we'd like to interview you I
think this is a very interesting yeah
set of requirements to achieve that
availability we'd love to talk to you
and find out how you achieved it yep
absolutely so yeah to Rakesh I think
like what is the requirements of your
app what are your SLA is what do you
need to be able to do and what sort of
failure rate can your stuff require and
that will tell you exactly what systems
you can build on top of
and also how quickly and how early you
can change them while they're sort of
running as well yeah and and that goes
back to as I said the episode with Paul
noose on where we talk about the
difference between SLO SLA and an actual
availability so I guess that answers the
question I think so too
I guess it's time to say goodbye before
that what are you up to what am i up to
so next week East Coast games conference
we talked about that previously and then
I'll be off to vector as well after that
we're doing a fundraiser extra life and
play crafting Game Jam are doing some
fun stuff for kids in hospital so like
two weekends of that from and that's on
the fifth of May and then again we have
another fundraiser on the 13th and then
after that I'm pretty excited I'm going
to Sweden I'm going to Nordic games
conference okay so I'll be presenting
there as well and where are you off to
so by the time this episode comes out
I'll be probably at the airport waiting
for my airplane to fly to China yes I'm
going to Shanghai for gopher Kanchana
and I'm going to be I'm going to be
meetings with some companies there but
for now I don't have any meetups
organized which is fine because probably
I will enter just attending some made us
up there yes
then on May I will be in New York for an
internal meeting but I will be also
speaking at the Google developer group
with Brett he will be speaking about
actions I will be speaking about Club
endpoints and gr PC so basically it's a
server less server last day it's going
to be lots of fun and also something
that I wanted to mention is that last
week I released a new episode of Joseph
funk and people are loving it it's on
the context package and you got already
like almost 5,000 views so pre excited
about it go check it out of you are into
that kind of things
sounds good all right Frances quell
thank you again for joining me for yet
another episode thank you Mark and thank
you all for listening
alright and we'll see you all next week
till next week
you